ayer la presidenta Xiomara Castro
sugirió por ejemplo que la situación
había sido producto de la negligencia de
las autoridades qué responsabilidad
tiene el Estado hondureño
el estado tiene 100% de responsabilidad
en lo que ha ocurrido puesto que mujeres
privadas de libertad en un centro
penitenciario están bajo el resguardo y
custodia del Estado Así que lo que ha
ocurrido con sus vidas es su
responsabilidad en un 100% para ya la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos había calificado el sistema
penitenciario de Honduras como
deshumanizado paupérrimo y corrupto y
contrario a la dignidad humana por qué
lo que hemos visto en las últimas horas
por qué no ha cambiado esta situación en
el país
Bueno en realidad Este es un tema
histórico los centros penitenciarios
están así desde siempre lo que es lo que
a este gobierno le ha tocado es una
herencia del pasado y entiendo que han
estado intentando Cambiar toda la
situación de los centros penitenciarios
sin embargo por ser un tema estructural
viejo el proceso es largo y lento y
entiendo también que como resultado de
esos cambios que han empezado a
implementarse al interior de los centros
penitenciarios es que ha venido toda
esta ola de
de violencia el interior de los centros
en oposición a renunciar a privilegios
que han sido desde todo punto de vista
ilegales con el beneplácito de los
encargados de dirigir estos centros
penitenciarios
ahora qué otros factores están
contribuyendo a que se dé esta situación
de violencia en las cárceles Y por qué
el gobierno no ha podido de alguna forma
controlar esta espiral de violencia en
los centros penitenciarios
Bueno uno de los temas centrales es el
tema de la corrupción las armas a los
centros penitenciarios no llegan solas
los teléfonos celulares y la instalación
de módem Para comunicación incluso
teléfonos satelitales armas de grueso
calibre no han llegado solas esa sin
duda han entrado con la complicidad de
policías militares y empleados
carcelarios corruptos creo que el
gobierno le ha faltado un poco de
agilidad en eso y
estructurar un nuevo sistema
penitenciario es una medida estructural
grande y profunda que debe llevar un
largo tiempo lo lamentable es que no se
ha iniciado sino recientemente Y por esa
tardanza es que hemos tenido pues este
motín horrible al interior de la cárcel
de mujeres pero también otros en las
cárceles penitenciarias masculinas
estas sugerencias de cambio vienen desde
hace muchos años pero qué garantías hay
de que este sistema en realidad pueda
cambiar en el corto plazo
bueno es una necesidad a gritos si no
cambia este sistema penitenciario actual
las consecuencias van a ser terribles y
peores yo no me atrevo a pensar hasta
dónde pueden llegar así que yo espero
que las medidas que para mí inicien con
la destitución del actual del del
ministro de seguridad puedan pasar por
otro tipo de medidas que toque otras
estructuras pero que además modifique la
configuración en su totalidad de los
centros penitenciarios para que no sigan
siendo una escuela del crimen sino que
empiecen a hacer unos espacios de
rehabilitación de las personas privadas
de libertad